what if i told you that you could build
your own ssd that is faster cheaper more
compatible
doesn't slow down and has a better
warranty than buying something that is
name brand off the shelf would you
believe that well today that is exactly
what we are doing i'll show you exactly
how and why you should build your own
ssd now if you recently purchased the
macbook or you're buying one you will
know that apple not only apple windows
manufacturers as well charge a killing
if you want to get more storage for
example if you're buying this macbook
air that i love you're gonna have to
spend 400
extra to move up to a one terabyte ssd
from that base 256 gig and this treblet
ssd with the custom m.2 inside costs you
280 bucks so you still keep the 256 plus
get an additional one terabyte of
insanely fast storage actually faster
than what is inside the macbook and you
can use this on any computer mac or pc
using thunderbolt or regular usb you are
not limited at all
now recently we have been highly
recommending the sabrint ssd that is
pre-built because it has a great price
tag and you can not only use thunderbolt
you also have that usb compatibility
compared to most other external ssds you
can either choose regular usb that is
much much slower or thunderbolt that is
much more expensive but now compared to
the previous custom ssd video that we
made we have this updated model that has
this capability as well and prices of
this ssd have come down as well giving
us the best external ssd that you can
get on the market for multiple reasons
that i will go into now i want to show
you guys the difference between the
version one that we built a year and a
half ago and this updated one today now
if you take a look at them you can see
that the new version on the right side
is actually slightly larger
and with that it is actually at the
bottom
and if we take the bottom of the top
parts both the bottom and the top parts
of the enclosure are thicker and this
gives us two improvements the first one
is that you can actually fit a deeper
ssd some are thicker and the second one
is this bottom piece that is solid
aluminum apart from the little cutouts
for your usb c plug so that just means
that you can run your drive for longer
and it's gonna stay cooler now in order
to build this incredible ssd we're gonna
need two things first this kit from
trableet that includes everything we
need along with an m.2 pci express ssd
the one that i'm using is a sabrin
rocket ssd for a few reasons now this is
a piece air express 4.0 ssd meeting it
has super fast speeds and even though we
are not going to achieve those speeds
and this external ssd over thunderbolt
because that limits it there are still
great reasons to use it the first one is
the physon controller that is super fast
and it is very very quick at writing
your data and not slowing down so the
slc cache which i'll talk about in a
minute is incredible now the other
reason is the price tag this one
terabyte drive comes in at
129
now it dropped quite a bit because the
competition for psja express 4 is a lot
bigger now and there are faster drives
but for us this one is perfect now the
trebley kit the new updated one includes
everything you need inside of it we have
the actual enclosure right here we can
open it up we have a little kit with all
the screws that are necessary including
deeper ones for different kinds of ssds
and this little thermal pad that's going
to take the heat and put it out from the
ssd now inside we also have two sets of
cables now this one right here is a more
expensive thunderbolt cable so it's nice
that it's in the box it's a shorter one
which i prefer and we also have a usb
cable that is usb-a on one side and then
usb-c on the other along with a little
adapter for it to be usb-c to see
and now let me show you just how easy it
is to build your own ssd we're going to
take off uh the baggie and the top half
we're going to grab our ssd there's a
little notch in here so it only goes in
one way
i'm going to go ahead and slip it in
here at an angle
push it down
i'm going to grab our screw
grab our little thermal pad that's going
to transfer all the heat
apply it to the top here
let's peel off the other side
all right i felt that contact right
there
and grab our four screws
and just screw them in with the included
little screwdriver and there you go we
are done in less than a minute i put
together this ssd
and now let's get into
why this thing is so much better in
pretty much every way than buying an
off-the-shelf pre-built
closure the first reason is
compatibility unlike the first version
that we built previously
this thing can connect to any computer
even if you don't have thunderbolt and a
lot of the thunderbolt ssds that are out
there
they don't offer that now we do have
that sabrand that we have been
recommending for a while and this also
offers it which is why we were
recommending it
but now this is the better solution the
second one is price point because the
ssd dropped even though the actual
enclosure itself is more expensive at
150 bucks compared to 130 the overall
price drop from 320 now down to 280
bucks now samsung's x5 that we tested is
350 along with the lassie one that also
supports usb type c it's the only one
that we tested other than the sabrent
that had that capability so you're
getting a drive that is very capable
it's compatible and it is priced fairly
well but it is also not the cheapest
drive out there because at 280 bucks
that is still sixty dollars more than a
sabrin's that comes in at one terabyte
and this is where we have to get into
performance the first thing we'll talk
about is slc cash because a lot of
people out there don't even know how
this works now with these ssds they
advertise speeds of up to say 2800
uh 2700 but in reality they never
actually reach that speed but that's not
the only thing that they don't reach
what slc cache is is a portion of the
ssd that can be super fast and reach
those speeds but if you have a file or a
folder that is larger than that chunk it
will actually slow down dramatically for
example those previous drives that we
tested even though some of them were
close to as cl as fast as our brand new
custom ssd
once you wrote between 20 to 50
gigabytes they slowed down
dramatically and sometimes were less
than half or maybe even a third of the
speed for the remainder and because of
that our custom ssd
wrote a 170 gigabyte file way faster
than those drives that are way more
expensive so if you're grabbing one of
these ssds you get the capability and
the ability to buy your own m.2 ssd and
this rocket that's pc express 4 and has
a 5 zone controller does not slow down
anywhere near with any any files at all
i think even 170 gigabyte file it still
ran at the full speed and it didn't
overheat like some of those other drives
so the performance is really good as far
as the slc cache now the actual full
speed performance is incredible as well
if you want to buy one of these segrents
that we recommended and you're not
picking up a four terabyte model like
this one but instead you're getting a
one terabyte model it is actually much
slower at about 1300 megabytes per
second on the right speed compared to
2400 or so that we got previously with
the version 1.0 so that is a massive
difference in write performance and the
read is fairly similar
but with the new version 2.0 that we
just built this actually goes up to 2550
right and 2650
read so it is even faster with the same
ssd
and you have the capability for usb now
the other difference is your warranty
since you can easily unscrew the ssd out
of this case you can send it back if
there's any issues and this ssd has a
five year warranty unlike most external
ssds that come with either a one
maybe a three year warranty if you're
buying a nice product so five years is
excellent and the five year warranty is
because the terabytes are written on
this ssd
it's a thousand eight hundred and if you
don't know what that is that's basically
the rating of the lifespan or how much
life you can expect out of your ssd so
this is a phenomenal ssd that we put
inside of here and for such an amazing
price so with all of that the speeds
that you're getting the compatibility um
and the sheer size of this thing and
weight and price you just cannot justify
spending 350 on something that is larger
has a worse warranty is slower and it
slows down dramatically compared to
building this yourself so if you're
somebody that bought a new macbook you
have a macbook air you don't want to pay
apple's prices or you want to be able to
use it for multiple computers
or even a pc laptop it just makes no
sense now to buy something that's
pre-made compared to building one of
these and this video is not sponsored by
treblet or say brand we just really
enjoyed these items and wanted to show
this off to you guys so all of the items
are linked down in the description below
you guys could go and check that out
click that circle above if you guys want
to subscribe and check out one of the
great videos right over there
max and i'll see you in the next video